all right uh politics doesn't have to be
entertaining it doesn't have to be
entertaining in the way that a TV show
or a movie has to be entertaining in
fact it's a problem that in many ways
our politics in the United States has
become one of the sideshow like an
action movie or whatever the case may be
rather than serious policy discussions
at the same time there's a difference
between entertainment and being a
completely
uninspiring and uh a pedantic uh bore in
the context of explaining to people what
you're going to do for them that would
say hey I think I'm going to vote for
you so when I'm going to play some clips
now for you of Ron DeSantis speech
yesterday in Iowa and tell you that he
seemed to be trying to bore the crowd to
death it's not that I mean DeSantis
needs to be doing the insults that Trump
has become known for or the nicknaming
or any of that that's not what I'm
saying what I am saying is that he is
boring the crowd to death with
meaningless slogans and bullet points
that even he doesn't understand and
certainly don't connect to any important
policy that would help people here is
the santis for example talking about the
debt deal that is being worked on and it
seems that that has been reached they
now have a debt deal deal which they're
acting like is going to change things we
were careening towards bankruptcy before
this debt deal and the country is still
careening towards bankruptcy after this
debt deal we need big reform to be able
to get our nation back on fiscal uh
solid fiscal ground what reform how does
that relate specifically to the economic
situations of the people in the crowd
the problem with this sort of speech is
that not only is it retreading the same
tired lines that Republicans have tried
for a while it's been years since this
sort of republicanism was even at the
center of the Republican party and this
is not in any way connecting with the
average voter about what the sandis is
going to do then DeSantis just shifts to
woke and he talks about competing in the
woke Olympics he just can't get away
from talking about woke woke woke you
should not have to compete in the woke
Olympics just to qualify for employment
or to get into a college Merit must
Trump identity politics
this is essentially his campaign and it
couldn't be I mean he it couldn't be
less inspiring thank you for being here
today today we'll talk about how the
history of the paper clip has completely
gone woke at this point in time you know
paper clips are these small metal
devices they used to hold sheets of
paper together but now they represent
woke ideology and some people even bend
them into LGBT shapes I saw a paper clip
painted in the pride flag colors and
we're not going to do that in Florida
and if I'm president we're not doing
that anywhere okay they're gonna paper
you realize teachers who want to talk
about gender affirming care are using
colored paper clips we're not going to
allow it in Florida and we're gonna make
the entire country floor it's it's
meaningless stuff it just it doesn't do
anything it doesn't connect with anyone
here's one more clip of DeSantis talking
about a faucian dystopia under covet in
Florida we made the choice to choose
facts over fear we chose education over
indoctrination right and we chose the
stand for Law and Order over rioting and
disorder sure we held the line when
Freedom itself hung in the balance I was
not going to let the State of Florida
descend into some type of falchian
dystopia where people's freedoms were
curtailed and their livelihoods were
destroyed no we stood up for people's
rights we protected people's jobs and
small businesses and guaranteed like
your Governor did that kids had a right
to be in school and get an education in
person five days a week in short Florida
we chose Freedom over faucism and we are
better off for having done that it seems
like these speeches were written by some
kind of poor like by chat GPT one you
know it's not even like the stuff that
three or four can write for them and it
just does not have winner written
anywhere all over it by the way for all
of his bragging about covid Florida with
the 10th highest per capita coveted
death rate 10th highest per capita covet
death rate so not exactly something to
brag about